so we've talked about how mathematics
can go places and understand concepts
where scientists you know are trying to
observe things but you know physically
cannot go okay well mathematics also
enables us to direct where science
should go where it can go somewhere but
it hasn't thought to gone there yet so
for example let's have a look at this
now you should recognize this this is
the solar system that you know and love
except it's not quite the solar system
you know and love because if you have a
look think with me the planets you name
that is mercury when we got that must be
Venus then earth then bars hey Jupiter
the big guy satin then Uranus the
sideways unusual guy no worrying about
the fact that we don't classify Pluto as
a planet anymore there is one object
missing from here namely maybe net you
okay now here's the thing for a very
very long time these were all of the
planets that we were aware of these are
the planets that we first saw with our
naked eye for instance Venus because it
is a cosine and it's very brilliant in
its color because of all its clouds it
reflects sunlight very effectively we
could see Venus for a long time in fact
Venus is sometimes called by Morningstar
because so bright Jupiter just by virtue
of being enormous okay also can be seen
with the naked eye if you know where to
look the rest of the guys can be we're
scene and identified by telescopes but
net you let's put them in the picture
now Neptune was not spotted for a long
time and the reason why is is is the few
reasons number one you guys know that
out the scale of this diagram is
somewhat inaccurate for example if this
is the Sun and we were there we'd all be
dead okay we have much much further away
from the Sun that this diagram shows and
everything is much further away from
each other the reason why is because if
you put all the planets eat a diagram
which was actually to scale there will
be
tiny tiny specks you wouldn't see
anything okay so this is not accurate
with regard to scale just to make it
more interesting okay but being that is
not accurate quinta scale I'll Neptune
Neptune is so so far away right because
it's very very far away that means it
absorbs and reflects less light from the
Sun right like there's less like
actually getting out to win a few years
which means less than it can bounce back
to us so that we can see the thing ok
doesn't mean it's invisible it just
means it's very very hard to spot ok and
so Neptune rebate for a long time are
undiscovered ok now how is it discovered
how is it discovered to help you
understand how mathematics is involved
and how it really guided the discovery
of nip shin let me ask you this question
so in kisser here's a terrible image cuz
I'm a pretty bad artist let's try Hey oh
that looks kind of Australia like all
right I guess yeah I don't know ok doing
that that looks like a ok there's a
right now again not to scale suppose I
put the move over here ok there's the
couple of craters that kind of thing
right now I'll ask you where an obvious
question ok and Cuba be right in between
the earth of the food right which of
these objects orbits the other one right
and clearly it's the moon orbiting the
earth right obviously like the birth is
kind of in the center of the picture and
there goes the boot racing around the
edges ok the only problem with that is
it's not really quite true I mean the
moon sort of does orbit the earth but to
illustrate to you how this is actually
not entirely accurate let me just let me
just imagine ok suppose you're still
happier
right but you took the mood and you
increased it in size and mass actually
that the size doesn't mean about as it
turns out it's really just an ass that's
important uh if you took the moon there
you go there's there's the MU naught
traders and pop marks that kind of thing
if you increased it so it was the equal
mass as you would you be but anyway you
get the idea if it was equal mass now
let me ask this question again in this
system which object orbits the other one
right does the mood still earth or is
this time is the earth gonna orbit the
moon okay now if you can imagine right I
want you to imagine now rather two
planets I want to imagine two people
okay so let's do it like this okay here
we go person number one and two okay now
if you look to people and they are both
holding each other's heads okay so if
they're both arms outstretched and they
are holding each other like this only
hands okay and swinging around each
other like throwing each other circle
okay if just like before as is in
reality if one object is much lighter
than the other one okay then this one is
going to stay put more or less and this
one is going to remove it a circle
around but if they are equal mass okay
then what will happen is as one spins
the other one will also spin these guys
are not going to one spin around the
other or the other spin round one they
are both going to spin around the point
in the center of it right in fact this
is why I between my math so much that
point is called the center of mass the
center of mass not on that point there
that point right in the middle of both
of food that's what they both go around
okay and so now if you were a feedback
so let's go back to our situation if the
objects were the same size then they
would orbit each other evenly okay now
even though they are not the same size
even though as we are aware the moon is
much much much smaller and our ways much
less has a much smaller mass this same
kind of principle of objects orbiting
each other around their center of mass
which because the earth is so massive
happens to be inside the earth that's
not here themself this happens all the
time right these objects are commonly
orbiting right obviously the mass of the
Earth affects the orbit of the moon but
the best of the moon also affects what's
happening on earth it tugs on earth just
a little bit right i mean the earth is
much bigger so it's it's tajuk war okay
but the bird is still tugging and it's
tightening in a significant way which is
why the part of the earth that can be
moved more easily namely the water
experiences tides because of the moon's
mass right the moon is tugging and you
know earth and the dust of the metals
are cut they don't go anywhere but the
water does because the water is
literally fluid so getting pulled and
stretched and squash and that's what we
experience tired so now that you
understand that even though the mood is
not that huge it has an impact on the
movement of the earth because they're
actually current orbiting one another
now you're ready to understand how math
is important here what was happening is
that of these parts that the the planets
trace around the Sun number one they are
mathematical parts
they follow certain equations basically
on the laws of motion that I'm Isaac
Newton Albert Einstein and so on
expressed about how objects should move
in relation to each other when you know
how big they are you know how fast
they're going etc okay they all have
these roughly elliptical orbits around
the Sun but but just as I've explained
here right not only are all of these
orbits shaped by the sun's mass all of
these orbits are also shaped by the
orbits of the other planets okay and the
easiest example of this is the see
Jupiter right and Jupiter is huge
obviously has the biggest part of the
sign of the biggest and gravitational
pull of any of the objects in size and
for that reason all of those asteroids
and comets that are sort of racing
around all over the place most of them
have their orbits significantly affected
by Jupiter okay in fact there's a theory
that really if Jupiter to resist us we
will get hit by way more asteroids of
that kind of the other celestial objects
flying through here because if it worked
there its gravitational pull not be
sucking thing towards it eating's toward
it and so in some ways Jupiter's kind of
shielded earth from a lot of his pads
but here's where neptr you comes in okay
people were observing all of the orbits
and they knew the laws of gravitation
how and the laws of motion how it should
work and they're in particular looking
at the orbits out here now if you know
how object is orbiting then you ought to
be able to know with some clever
predictions where to look in the sky
each night from whatever location you
are on the planet to find such as such a
celestial object rather to star or a
mood or a plan okay and here's what sort
of book was happening they were looking
at these planets out towards the edge of
the solar system in particular they were
looking at your age okay and they were
saying hot on we know where this planet
should be we know are looking at the
mathematics of it we know where it
should be ending up but we look at the
telescope we look at the spot it's not
there it's not we're mathematically we
would expect it to be so something has
gone wrong I go I understanding your
physics
his arm has got to be fixed up here
somewhere right well they crunched the
numbers that check the equations over
and over again a little bit like when
you get a question in exercise and
you're getting an entire you turn to the
back of the book and then a match what's
going on right now they checked over and
over again their calculations were
correct but that plan in it right that
second last planet solar system still
wasn't wearing they expected so they had
to draw an inescapable mathematical
conclusion that there was some object
out there that they didn't know about
that they didn't have a record on that
must be affecting this orbit right in
fact they're not only do that they had
to be something there but based on what
they expected of the orbits of the
planets and what they observe and the
discrepancy between them they calculated
the exact massive location predicted of
where this you know mysterious objects
should be such that it would produce the
orbit that they observed okay so you can
see here obviously the science of
important there were observations and
repetitions and hypotheses and all I
kind of thing but it was crunching the
mathematical models of what was
happening and what they expected to
happen that told them he is where the
object should be and as they actually
did the math magicians went to a an
observatory excuse me they said look
we're predicting an object you should be
able to find it right here on this
particular night turn your telescopes
there and you'll find it people thought
they were crazy right but once they got
an actual set of astronomers with an
actual telescope to agree they pointed
details got there and the dude was
discovered it was a biomedical Discovery
okay so remember how I said mathematics
goes places like black holes that
science can't actually go right that is
true and then science comes into
confirms the fact that these these
should exist mathematics also tells
science okay we'll watch sort of things
should you actually experiment with and
repeat and try to observe because you
know if you just think if you don't know
s are pay right like Oh what should I
what should I experiment what
I test your imagination can take you so
far right who would guess to search at a
particular spot except for randomly well
the vastness of space will just make it
so very difficult to discover things
like that a planet in our very own solar
system mathematics told us gravitational
dynamics told us that's where it should
be okay right one last example for you
of mathematics again taking going
somewhere where science couldn't go yet
and therefore really leading the way for
where science should go okay